What's your name? I'm Aaron and where you from, Detroit, Michigan
Cool, and do you have an example of something you're scared to share with people?
Not anymore
But in the past I used to be scared to share my sexuality
When did you get over that?
You actually it takes a long time to get over it
Amongst close friends I'd say I was about 19
but with my family it wasn't till I was about 22 23 and then
With everybody not caring anymore
It wasn't until I was
I'm 40 now. So it shows you I've only been free for a short while
Can ask the fault question sure, what was what do you think you're scared of?
For me it had a lot to do with
being prejudged or the
being
Presumed to be a certain way
I wanted people to know me first before they interpreted my sexuality
So I was scared of rejection. I think if you look at the whole rejection
I think a big one would be fake
It's like I am a Christian and that's not something I'm ashamed of but I know going into it with a stranger sometimes
Something as simple as faith can turn people off like that
And so I would like to like talk to them first and have an opportunity
Because sometimes when you if they find that out right away
They could shut down and so with a stranger that would be something that's a little I'm a little scared too
Just because of how the world operates today
maybe things that like happened in the past inside your household are like
like deep and maybe don't want to share with other people, but sometimes those getting those out really just
Lets you just be yourself more instead of like a closed show
I'm scared to share that I don't like being alone. So I find
Different people
to
crazy, I find different people to find these little things that I like and even then I don't even want to settle down so
I just keep hopping from person to person
Why do you think you're scared to share that with people?
because people and this day and age think that it's bad to be open and to
Everyone wants a relationship. Everybody wants to get married. Everybody wants to have kids and
when you're a single person and you don't really want to settle down you want to be openness kind of like a
What's the word I'm trying to use taboo
My ethnicity oldest my ethnicity I really like that
Because I want it not to matter but it matters yeah
I'm scared to share with people that I have a fear of drowning
Being bipolar that I stutter sometimes. I'm afraid of the dark. I am terribly afraid of heights. I
Am a very grounded person, but I feel alone
My own insecurities, I'm afraid to show my emotions
Probably my anxiety my anxiety level that I have depression and anxiety
Because a lot of people are judgmental
And I honestly I don't want sympathy for it. I don't want people to look at me differently
So and I don't to use it as a crutch, so I kind of just keep it to myself for the most part. I
guess you could say like I'm pretty like
reclusive and like social anxiety and
If you like don't really know me, I'm like really quiet
so that's something like people don't really know about me and that's like something I don't really share with people but I
try my best to like
Fit into normal society like acting normal, but it's something that I deal with like every day
That's the whole question. Sure. Why do you think that you might be scared to share that with people?
Because I think people will think of me differently
and like, you know just
It's like judgment and then that just leads to negative thoughts and such
that I'm very shy I
Don't like to let people know how shy I am. Oh because they'll take advantage of you if they find out you're not aggressive
Self-promoting
Probably just that I'm afraid my car's gonna break down all the time
Because you know, it's all about perception. Um, it's about
You know, it's it's how you show yourself to the world so people think differently about you if you like tell them steps wrong
Versus if you act like everything is okay. I
guess my biggest thing is that
We're always taught to pretend that everything is always okay and that we're really successful and that we're doing a lot better than we are
So I guess my big fear is to actually tell people that half the time. I'm really freaked out
I have no idea what I'm doing and I'm definitely afraid that I'll fail
It's something I'm fighting with right now. Actually, it's just to even admit that I have fears because
everyone does and sometimes
You want to tell yourself you don't but you know, there's some deep stuff with everybody that there's some fear somewhere
You know growing up being a poor kid, you know, I didn't grow up with really anything
I was homeless with my mom growing up and
I've done a lot to be successful. I was the first person to graduate college in my family
But I still have that fear of
You know
Being that way that I had to grow up. You know what I mean?
Being homeless or being a less fortunate kid growing up
Especially in San Diego where a lot of kids have a lot of things and you can really notice the difference of not having things
That's my biggest fear
What am I too scared to share with you? I
Mean we just came from a music festival. So and it was at a nudist resort. So there is a lot of you know
Like lots of uninhibited energy. So for now this is like freshly off of that. It's kind of
funny to think of what am I too scared to share with people, you know, like
you
know old open new just walking around like it's no big deal and and then it sets the whole energy for the whole best to
be like
Just no inhibitions. So, um, I don't know what am I too free to show people I
Need to sing more and I'm a vocalist
And I'm a violin player and people tell me to sing all the time
Sometimes I'm just scared to do it being an artist. I never wanted to
Play solo violin or solo viola growing up. I always want to be in a group in anarchist dress
So that's definitely something I do now today that I used to be too scared to share with people
But I've gotten over I'm a performer now, so that's all I do
Wow
I'm not scared about much
Or anything really got another question. No
I mean, that's awesome that you're not scared now
How about I do feel like at this point in your life in my skin? Has there been the point in your life?
Where you might have been what that I used to be scared of? Oh
Man, I'm trying to remember. Oh gosh, maybe should let me think about it. Yeah
Well, let's see the reason why I'm not afraid of anything
it's because I give myself a lot of freedom and
I'm I'm not attached to the outcome of things
Does that make sense?
What's up guys, my name is Brian and I'm the owner of this channel
I'm also the person behind the camera and I thought I'd take a minute
To thank all the subscribers I gained so far and maybe ask new years to hit the subscribe button if you liked this episode
Or if you're a fan of my channel in general, I mean a lot
Thank you